[Music]
who's this guy who's this wonderful
anime guy you keep showing me who one
punch man that's his superhero name sick
it's awesome that's the best they could
come up with that's probably what it
translates to one punch man oh it's like
Japanese no like that's what it is oh
it's just one punch it looks like
[__] one punch
I mean bro the that's every film ever
obvious ass titles yeah that's true so
you gotta Market [__] man what are
dumbass American Minds bro not yet never
seen that it's so good it's okay okay he
looks like a little cancer boy it's
hilarious yeah it's oh it's funny yeah
he's like better than any superhero ever
because he does one punch but he's bored
as [__] and doesn't like know it oh so
he doesn't like to use the punch right
away he just waits he just like it does
nothing like he just lightly hits
someone and they die and it's over well
so he would rather see cities get
destroyed because he's bored I'm gonna
wait to punch this guy basically oh geez
what a piece of [__] there's other
superheroes oh man hey if you were a
superhero who would you be one punch man
I'd be Superman
because you're because you [__] you
want to have sex with people that's why
what you still want to be hot that's why
you want to be super oh well either him
or like Iron Man Iron Man I'd be [__]
I'd be uh the thing from the Fantastic
Four yeah I would be Nightcrawler I
would be Nightcrawler
I would [__] steal so much [__] I'd
be Hulk with a regular sized penis that
that would be scarier than the Hulk
himself that'd be the Hulk with a little
pathetic penis uh look you call him
little I I I I had a nightmare a few
months ago that your penis was regular
stats no that there was a uh there was a
T-Rex running around with a giant
proportionally sized human penis oh damn
it it scared the [__] out of me bro is
this this is this mid-journey
crawler from x-ray why would you want to
be Nightcrawler because you can uh can
we look up the X-Men scene from like
2001 I like the speed the guy who in
that in X-Men first Class that scene
where the building explodes and he goes
through and saves everybody oh killer
yeah quicksilvers play this [__]
Nightcrawler oh yeah he's telling me you
would want to be this I'd be [__]
blue just so I could do this just so you
could kill the president yep does he
kill the president no for the audio
listener you're just gonna have to suck
this one up
it's a scene from X-Men the sound design
is awesome
matching the portrait
and is the president like trying to kill
all the yeah
are you lost
and he's got a tail come on uh so he's
on monkey mode
[Music]
multiple subjects Mr President security
breach Jackie Lee let's get him out to
the car
if he can see the place in his mind he
can go there whoa
I would never pay for a meal ever again
yeah this is a very you uh character to
pick I would just why why because it's
specific and it's a like look we got the
same eyes bro
foreign
cool music
yeah lock it down dude yeah
damn you guys care about the president
that much
I'd be like no
look at this [__] and you can do karate
come on yeah
this is the only time martial arts is
effective
[Music]
get that
that's pretty tight
yeah I'd be I'd be doing dine and dash
renting expensive cars and they're like
okay uh we just need your credit card
goodbye
how does he visual like if he hasn't
seen it before in his life
he can still visualize it yeah
oh I remember this shot from the trailer
oh dude and this [__] uh you know
food coloring and water effect yeah
wow really good special effects for the
time especially yes
oh now he's gone I was gonna kiss the
president
I've got you in my sights
oh freaky
I don't want those teeth though who
stops it
whoa Mr President I love you I'd be the
Nightcrawler but with my smile
I don't want his teeth you know who's
the lamest one the guy with the [__]
trait playing cards who throws Gambit
shut your damn mouth right okay
[Applause]
too he just throws cards he just throws
cards right
yeah yeah okay yo look look at Gambit
all right I take that back you guys yeah
dude you'd be a [__] sex symbol are
you kidding me you passed the test lose
a hand in poker good night yeah well
that's called being a sore loser yeah so
that's called being so gambits of sore
loser no that sounds that's called being
Gambit so he's a he's just a superhero
with a gambling addiction yeah yeah yeah
yeah that's why he's got a five o'clock
shadow he's [__] broke they made him
that good oh yeah they picked up [__]
weirdest dude for him
um the guy who looks like the kid who
played Elvis but older yes yeah
Taylor's Stuart what superhero would you
be man uh Superman or Iron Man or
um Ant-Man uh no not Ant-Man uh someone
who you know [__] rocks
oh no Batman is [__] he can't even
move his damn head he's gonna move his
whole torso torso God what a [__] at
least Iron Man You're you got the same
amount of wealth but at least you've got
Charisma you got sex appeal yeah you got
uh yeah you want it all man you you want
to be a superhero and sexy
I mean I'm not really thinking of the
sexy part I'm just thinking about it
would rock to fly and it would rock to
um Fly basically that's it that's all I
want I just want to fly I want to be the
Green Goblin and just blow up Tesla
factories
or or Spiderman Spiderman would be cool
too young
just jizz on people with your hand
okay
one of the [__] was come the whole time
man
it wasn't even it wasn't even Webb it's
just really sticky gum no no like like
it's like
it's still a web but it's like his nut
oh yeah sure so it feels good every time
he does it oh
oh that's
that's a swing he's tired between each
swing
just hanging
[__] yeah
look at that dome right there dude come
on man don't disrespect me with the
[__]
show me the actual Green Goblin like the
comic book version that's not disrespect
I mean that one is ice cold but
Sam raimi's uh
Spider-Man 2 is one of the best movies
ever yeah yeah yeah perfect actually no
yeah you're right you're right that's
way cooler than the [__] original my
bad yeah
toy is horrendous
dude that that that that that is [__]
for the audio listener it's truly a
Green Goblin
to the left what the [__] all the does
he have waves
that [__] has waves are you
kidding me